everybody it's no real comfortable a
good way to start this so let's just
jump right in if you don't know what's
been happening over these last few weeks
Andy signor was fired almost three weeks
ago after multiple women came forward on
social media with allegations of sexual
harassment and abuse this was news that
was a shock to all of us
Andy was for I think everyone here not
just our boss but someone that we
counted as a friend and we found out
overnight that he was not the person
that we knew or that we thought he was
and it's taken a lot of time for us to
process that to ask the questions that
need to be asked and to feel comfortable
coming forward and just talking to you
guys and being able to say everything
that is in our brains and that we want
to get across first and foremost I want
to say that you know I think all of us
have been very encouraged and heartened
and and really touched by the support
that the fans have shown us personally
and I think we would all just ask that
you return that support tenfold to every
woman who's been brave enough to come
forward and share her story this is
something that's happening all over
Hollywood right now and and and has been
happening everywhere and the only way
that these things stop happening is for
people to be brave enough to speak out
and come forward so any support that
you've shown us is great but we also ask
that you share that with everyone who's
come forward not just about Andy
but anyone who shares a story about
anybody this is an important change it's
a change that needs to happen and people
coming forward is what makes that happen
Andy is fired and he's gone he will not
be coming back we'd be lying to say that
Andy wasn't a big part of screen junkies
but Andy is not screen junkies and
I hope that we can help rebuild a lot of
the trust that was lost because so many
of the people that came forward were
from our fan community and we recognized
that for someone so close to all of us
to betray that trust that's really
heartbreaking and we hope that we can
help rebuild that so we're going to talk
about some things and we always of
course one hear what the community has
to say and this is step one of a really
long road toward hopefully building
something bigger and better going
forward so yeah and we are aware that in
addition to the horrific betrayal of
trust to the community that we really do
love and care about there were serious
questions about how Defy handled defy HR
in particular handled the women who came
forward and their cases and we took that
very very seriously and we gathered
together and took our times this is why
we have not been here this is why we
have not been making videos we met with
each other we met with défi we outlined
steps forward to ensure that this would
not happen again and that is our number
one goal these steps include a third
party coming in to assess what happened
and provide an outline of procedures
forward that make it safe for women to
come forward that looks at what could
have been done better what can we do in
the future
and that provides hopefully a pathway to
rebuilding trust in this community yeah
so basically though those those minimum
sets of expectations we laid out have
been met otherwise we wouldn't be here
today and you can read about them I
assume there's like a link below or
something to the effect of the public
statement that that talks about this
third party coming in talks about we're
all getting sexual harassment training
not just managers at the company we're
gonna have a code of conduct for how we
can interact with fans that in essence
should make it easier to make sure that
people who violate that fan personality
relationship can be suspended or fired
much quicker than they were and and yeah
we we hope to maybe now make some more
positive changes just on the channel
itself to to just make this a better
place certain things will be the same
I think honest trailers is going to
continue until the entropic heat death
of the universe it'll always be around
as long as screen junkies is around the
rest of the stuff we're figuring it out
we welcome your input
we're all having these discussions of
what to do with everything else we want
to come back better it's not all gonna
come back right away
in fact the first couple episodes of sju
which if you guys don't watch some
screen jockeys news will be different in
tone and we're gonna have some
conversations in public that we've been
having in private before we get back to
to our regular scheduled programming but
yeah we hope that this can after all the
hurt and all the pain that he's caused
so many people that we can maybe move
forward and make screen junkies a better
place than it was yeah yeah he you know
sort of on that note he broke something
that we all we all love at this table
that we know you guys love and you've
made that very clear
and we hope we can sort of build that
you know into something better so yeah
echoing that will be approaching some
semblance of normalcy you know slowly
it's going to be a slow transition back
in if I think we all agree would feel
fake of tomorrow we just gave you a Geo
storm review so yeah we're we're gonna
there's going to be sort of some special
videos of things that we want to talk
about and then but that won't be int
we're
you know that we're sort of a part of
this process we're committed to it
screen Jessica screen junk is going to
be a little more I guess the part of the
world I don't know how else to put it
and yeah I'll just I'll echo everything
that you guys said yeah it's it's been a
difficult time but we're hoping to you
know move forward now and you know
stronger and more aware and yeah and in
a safe environment and I've been here
for five years over five years here at
screen junkies I'm lucky to be a part of
this community and thank you to everyone
who's been reaching out and there have
been you know a lot of kind words and we
really heard from you know the fans so I
just yeah just want to do right by the
fans it because you guys have just
create helped us create something that's
really cool and fun and I look forward
to you know continuing and getting back
to the good times but unappreciated I
appreciate everyone knowing and
understanding that we needed to take
this time well now you know we've been
here we started a fix to the same day
we've been here over five years together
we ran and I think something else that
we really I think a big motivating
factor because we all had some very
serious questions on our own about what
do we do what can we do do we wanna do
we even want to come back you know and I
think what so much of what brought all
of us back was the idea of you know
sexual abuse and harassment is something
that is finally there's a spotlight on
it and it's not gonna go away but I
think there's also spotlight being put
on the wider scope of a just abuse and
harassment in this industry and just in
general and I think what a lot what we
want to do is not just rebuild the
channel but help make this a community
that is more accepting that is a place
where people feel comfortable coming in
we've you know we've heard from so many
fans in the last few years that have
said hey you know I used to comment on
your video
I used to be involved and engaged and I
just can't do it anymore because I feel
like I'll be attacked I feel like you
know that there's I can't be a part of
the discussion and that's something that
we want to focus on as well as we want
this to be a place for movie fans to
come and talk about movies and and learn
and and and grow and and and have their
love of film appreciated and and
nurtured and not yelled at and so we are
going to be setting some internal
standards just communities guidelines
that we kind of help help us foster the
community we want to build and we are
taking the burden on ourselves to look
at some of what we've done and said hey
we there were some things we did that
invited divisive 'no sand that invited
you know argument and that's not what we
want so we're even looking at ourselves
and saying like what can we do better to
to make this not a place for you know
disagreement but a place for sincere
discussion and conversation and and I
think that's really that's certainly
what brought me back was the chance to
take this and really do it learn from it
and and and we have a chance to rebuild
this community in a way that we think is
gonna be very positive and better yeah
yeah that's the goal is to take this and
create any measure of good that we can
out of it so thank you again from all of
us I think so just sticking with us and
being patient and kind of having faith
as we worked our way through this it
took some time and it's gonna be an
ongoing process but we'll we'll be back
yeah I mean believe me I want to get
back to having fun again but we needed
to I mean I think we were all just like
it was a gut punch and it was it
required time to to heal and talk about
and yeah make sure that nothing like
this you know can happen in the future
yeah we're gonna go back to building
this channel
and help trying to repair this and we
hope you'll join us okay soon